Bah, que vois-je ?
Un téléphone !
Mais à qui appartient-il ?
Bien le bonjour apprenti Inspecteur,
Aujourd'hui nous allons devoir résoudre une terrible énigme
A qui appartient ce téléphone que je viens de trouver?
Et est ce que cette personne va bien?
Vous venez de trouver un téléphone. Découvrez la vérité.
Parfois la vérité est sous nos yeux mais on ne la vois pas
Notez ça hein.
Il est 22h du soir on est le 31 janvier
Et on a reçu 4 nouveaux messages
De Papa, où est tu passé?
Il a envoyé ça à 21h34
25 minutes plus tard il envoie un message et il dit :
On est tous vraiment inquiets, dit nous que tout va bien. Ta mère veut appeler la police
Papa
Donc c'était il y a deux minutes seulement qu'il a reçu ce message
Si je remonte la dernière fois que j'ai répondu c'était à 10h37 du matin
Putain
Joyeux anniversaire mon fils. Je sus tellement fier de l'homme que tu est devenu
On fêteras ça dignement ce soir, mais sois préparé à une grosse surprise pour tes 18 ans, Papa
Donc je suppose qu'il avais rendez vous à 20 heures à la maison pour fêter son anniversaire avec ses amis
ça c'était en Décembre donc c'était il y a deux mois
Maman demande si Melissa vient diner se soir à la maison
Non on est pas vraiment en bon termes en ce moment
Ouuuuhh
On a tous connu ça gamin
tu sais fut un temps il y avait une inspectrice Squeezie
J'l'ai tuée
Ouh ! Le 30 Janvier il lui dit
Je suis en train de faire les courses pour la soirée de demain
Je me demandais combien on sera, est ce que Melissa sera là. Papa
Et le gamin, qu'on va appeler Paul a répondu :
Non mais s'il te plait arrête de me demander ça
Ok, clairement elle l'as larguée et il arrive pas à s'en remettre, clairement
Est ce qu'il y a pas la meuf Mélissa?
Désolé ça me stresse
Ok alors à partir de quel moment ça a merdé entre eux?
Mélissa a aidé sa grand mère a déménager apparemment
Oh putain alerte embrouille
Alerte Embrouille!
Ah! Qu'est ce qu'on déteste être tous dans cette situation les gars
Tu as fait quoi aujourd'hui ? Je suis allé jouer aux jeux de société
Avec qui?
Robert, Anne, Martin...
Il n'y avais pas Alice?
Si
Bah pourquoi tu me mens alors?
Bah je t'ai pas menti j't'ai juste pas dit qu'elle était là
*Rire*
Ça c'est la pire phrase de merde
Ne dites jam-
votre meuf elle va se vénère direct
Pourquoi tu ne m'as pas dit dès le départ qu'Alice était là. Tu me cache quelque chose, c'est ça?
Parce que justement dès que je parle d'Alice tu fais une crise de jalousie.
Je t'ai déjà répété mille fois qu'Alice c'était juste une amie
Mais c'est ma meilleure amie, je ne compte pas arrêter de la voir
Et il faut vraiment que tu arrêtes de me mettre la pression à ce sujet
Booooo
Il a porté ces balls mon gars
Il les a posées comme ça
Il a pas l'air de mentir mais bon dans le doute
ça peut être sa maîtresse hein
Et je parle pas de celle que t'as vu cette après midi dans ton école de cassos.
Pardon, je suis bête. Mais j'ai juste besoin d'être rassurée de temps en temps tu sais
Je n'ai jamais connu d'amitié homme-femmes avant toi et Alice
tu est la seule que j'aime~~~~
Oui, on connaît bien ça
N'empêche je suis sûre que je serai moins jalouse si tu me la présentais un jour
Ne t'inquiète pas ça arriveras
ta meuf est méga jalouse de ta meilleure amie
Le meilleur moyen pour qu'elle sois plus jalouse c'est que tu lui présente !
Donc on vient d'assister à une petite dispute
anodine entre deux jeunes gens d'un jeune couple
Rien d'alarment
Le 24 Novembre elle lui dit :
Je suis à l'aéroport, je pense à toi. On se revoit au nouvel an
Il lui dit passe de bonnes vacances
*souffle* Nan
Ne me dis pas qu'il y a eu l'amour de vacances qui a tout pété
Et six jours plus tard il lui envoies un message pour lui dire
Tu me manques. C'était long cette semaine de vacances sans te voir
Je parie que tu en as profité pour voir Alice en plus
Ce à quoi il va bien sûr répondre
Oui je l'ai vu une ou deux fois c'est ma meilleure pote t'as pas à t'inquièter
Mais non je ne l'ai pas vue. Je n'ai pensé qu'à toi toute la semaine. Hâte d'être demain
*imite le canard*
et donc le lendemain, j'ai prévu une grosse surprise pour ce soir
Quelque chose pour vraiment célébrer la nouvelle année
avec un clin d'oeil
Allez je t'envoie un indice en photo
De la lingerie sexy~~~~
Bon qu'est ce qui a pu foirer là,
Pourquoi vous m'avez appelé là il y a pas à enquêter là
Vous voulez juste me foutre le seum par rapport à ma vie sentimentale c'est ça?
Je suis désolé mais je ne viendrais pas
Je sais que tu espérais beaucoup de choses pour ce soir mais il est temps de l'admettre
On est vraiment a un stade différent de nos vies
et on n'a plus les mêmes attentes. On est plus les ados d'autrefois.
Je me rends compte à quel point c'est horrible de te dire ça comme ça
Je te souhaite tout de même de passer une bonne soirée tout de même,
et de trouver ton bonheur en 2016
Mon instinct d'enquêteur me dit que quelqu'un lui a mis la pression
pour qu'il quitte Mélissa
Nan mais attends tu rigoles là ? Tu me quittes? C'est quoi ce délire ?
Tout c'est passé bien jusqu'à maintenant, il s'est passé quelque chose pendant les vacances?
tu ne peux pas me quitter on s'aime!
Il ne s'est rien passé pendant les vacances
J'ai juste l'impression de ne plus ressentir la même chose qu'avant
Attends tu ne vas pas casser notre relation sur un coup de tête
Viens à la maison parlons en face plutôt
Elle a pas tord
Non, ma décision est prise. Et j'ai envie de passer la soirée seul désolé
Va te faire foutre
réponse correcte
Je sais que ça parait vraiment con de te dire tout ça maintenant
mais je suis vraiment désolé de tout ce qu'il s'est passé
Tu es une personne vraiment géniale et tu mérite mieux qu'un connard comme moi
Rah sa ça m'énerve ! C'est la phrase du mec qui n'assume pas
tu mérites mieux, c'est pour sa que je te quitte
C'est vraiment pas parce que Alice elle a des gros seins et que j'adore ça
Mais c'est p-
Dit moi ce que je peux faire pour t'aider à aller mieux
demande moi ce que tu veux
tu sais que je déplacerais des montagnes pour toi
Je te veux toi tu es et tu as toujours été l'unique personne que je voulais dans ma vie
Tout sauf ça, Si je peux faire quoi que ce soit d'autre pour me faire pardonner ou t'aider à aller mieux dit le moi
Je ne veux plus jamais entendre parler de toi
S'il te plait, ne m'écris plus, ne viens plus me parler à l'école, évite moi. Tu es toxique Sam, tu es la pire chose qui me soit arrivée
Ok inspectons sur sa conversation avec Alice
c'est une très grande conversation je vais inspecter pour vous
Oh, Putain!
Bon Alice est Célibataire
elle a une copine qui est en couple avec un mec
et cette copine est extrêmement jalouse vis-à-vis de ce mec
Sam lui réponds que sa copine Mélissa est aussi très jalouse
C'est là qu'Alice a une réponse plutôt triste
Tu as une copine? Je ne savais pas
Une minute de silence pour Alice
Bon on feras qu'une seconde
Euh oui pardon désolé de ne t'en avoir jamais parlé
Mec,
tu mettais une petite option sur Alice avoue
Euh c'est cool. Je suis juste un peu surprise. Je ne sais pas pourquoi, j'ai cru que tu étais plus à fond sur les garçons
Oh, ça c'est inattendu
Oh! J'ai croyais qu'Alice elle étais deg parce qu'elle était un petit peu sur Sam
mais pas du tout elle croyais qu'il étais totalement homosexuel
Je crois que j'aime les deux, mais je sais pas trop encore. Garde le pour toi.
Quoi? (virilité 100%)
Mais attends, mais arrêtez les rebondissements là
Ah Il a peut être rencontré un mec et c'est pour ça qu'il a quitté Mélissa
Putain mais ce téléphone qu'on a trouvé c'est un Drama exceptionnel
Oh, j'ai trouvé un message intéressant,
Le 6 janvier il a envoyé un message à Alice
Alice il faut vraiment d'un truc grave.
C'et à propos de Mélissa
J'ai besoin de te parler répons réponds réponds
Ils se sont donnés rendez vous dans un parc pour parler
Putain, du coup il y a pas de trace de ce qu'ils ont pu se dire
Le soir Alice lui dit je serais toujours là pour toi
même si j'ai été surprise par ta grosse confession
sache que tu peux toujours compter sur moi
C'est quoi cette grosse confession? c'est ça, c'est ça l'élément clef de l'enquète
Le 31 Janvier, Alice lui envoie un message pour lui souhaiter Joyeux anniversaire
18 ans, c'est un homme,
la barbe tout ça
Et Sam lui dit comme je le craignait cette soirée est bien naze
Il était donc à 19h46 à cette putain de soirée
Il y étais à 19h46 mais à 20h15
son père le cherchait
Il est donc parti entre 19h46 et 20h15
ensuite Alice lui reproche de donner trop d'importance aux dates
et que c'est un homme etcetera etcetera
et là il y a un brouillon
Merci pour tes conseils mais tu sais je n'accorde pas tant d'importance aux dates
Je te laisse on me reproche d'avoir le nez collé au téléphone au lieu de profiter de la soirée
Puis mon père s'apprête à offrir son grand cadeau surprise
Vous l'aurez compris, c'est donc, cette photo
Son daron avec la moto surprise
il ce met bien cousin
tin' ma théorie du début elle était bien nulle à chier avec la contre soirée et tout
*rires*
Notez surtout pas ça dans vos cahiers hein
Donc il a pris la moto, il est parti et il est jamais revenu
Donc sois il a eu un accident sois il s'est rendu quelque part et on ne sais pas où
Il est peut-être allé voir Melissa
Il s'est mis à Lovebirds, l'application de rencontre le 18 janvier
donc je pense que le code ça doit être 1801
merde
Bon j'ai regardé le calendrier c'est la même chose qui se passe chaque semaine sauf
Le festival de BD le 19 décembre
Nani!
AH fallait la marquer en mode ricain
le mois avant le jour
tin' je pourrais jamais être enquêteur aux états-unis
ça c'est clair
Oh, de toute façon depuis que Trump est élu ça vaut plus le coup hein?
Description, je suis un fille gentille de 18 ans aux yeux bleus
Mais tu es un homme Sam
Je n'ai pas de photo de moi car je ne me sens pas vraiment à l'aise avec mon physique
Mais peut-être que j'en partagerais une, un jour
l n'y a pas de honte a être homosexuel mais inscrit toi en tant qu'homosexuel
Sinon tu va décevoir des mecs hein
Ha les mecs hétéros qui vont penser tomber sur la femme de leur vies ils vont être déçus.
Alors, lire mes messages
Moi ce qui va m'intéresser c'est le dernier, le 28 Janvier
:o
il as beaucoup discuté avec cet homme
Donc Sam dit à cet homme
J'ai vraiment aimé ton profil la partie où tu parlais ouvertement du fait que tu étais bisexuel et que tu te battais contre toutes formes de discriminations
Ha il est franco quand même James ils vont tout les deux ce dire qu'ils sont des hommes
Il y auras pas de douilles
Donc une semaine Phil envoie un SMS à Sam
Hello, Sam comment va tu? C'était comment avec ta famille?
Salut Phil, Je n'ai pas trop le moral je t'avoue
Je t'avoue c'était vraiment pas top avec ma famille
Ah bon? Qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé?
On va dire que je viens d'une famille assez conservatrice pas super ouverte questions LGBT
Tu vois ce que je veux dire?
Ouais carrément tu as tenté de faire ton coming-out ou a s'est mal passé?
Oh non avec eux ce n'est même pas la peine d'essayer
Je sais qu'ils me mettraient à la porte direct
C'est quoi ce délire de grogner son enfant parce qu'il n'a pas la même orientation sexuelle que toi?
Oh la beauferie
Aïe ça craint tu crois que ça les dérangeraient tant que ça que leur fille soit bisexuelle?
Oh ça je ne sais pas, ça passerait peut-être mais je ne pense pas qu'ils acceptent facilement l'idée que leur fils soit en fait une fille, peut être bisexuelle
Ah c'est un transexueeel
C'est pour ça que dans sa bio elle se décrit comme une fille
Du coup Phil lui dit qu'il connaît aussi des transsexuels,
Du coup Sam lui pose des questions pour savoir comment ça se passe dans leurs vies
Il explique par exemple qu'il a un copain ou dès que des gens apprennent qu'il est trans
Ils viennent le voit et ils lui demande 'et du coup pour le sexe ça se passe comment?'
C'est pas le genre de questions que tu demandrais à une question que tu connais à peine
Pourtant quand ils savent que la personne en face est transexuel ils se permettent tout
ça m'étonne pas
Sam explique son mal être autour de ça
et qu'il peut pas en parler à grand monde
et qu'il a peur que sa mère fouille sa chambre et tombe sur son téléphone
et donc sur des trucs sensibles
Phil lui dit qu'il y a une solution pour ça
Une application qui s'appelle 'calculatrice'
et qui ressemble à une vraie calculatrice.
mais si u tapes un code dedans et qu'ensuite
ta mère
et qu'ensuite tu tapes égal,
sa ouvre un truc caché ou tu peux ranger des trucs sensibles
Ma meilleure Alice le sait je peux toujours lui faire confiance
C'est bon à entendre parle moi un peu d'Alice je l'aime déjà
Je l'ai rencontrée il y a pas longtemps au club de jeu de sociétés où j'allais tous les dimanches
Le truc c'est, j'y allais en tant que fille
en tant que Samantha
Je portais même une perruque
WOW, mais c'est super courageux je suis content que tu ais osé le faire
+1 Phil
Merci mais ça s'est pas passé comme prévu
au final une sale pétasse s'en ai rendu compte
et elle menace de dire aux autres si je retourne là bas, je n'y vais plus
Je comprends pas ça hein
Y a les gens ils on satisfaction
à faire chier les autres
c'est ouf!
Il fait ce qu'il veut s'il veut venir avec une perruque
S'il veut y aller à poil
Il y va à poil
Putain!
Excusez moi je m'énerve je me transforme en Angry Squeeie
là ça va pas
On va devoir trouver le code de
Euh~~~~
La calculatrice
Je vais réessayer toutes les dates du calendrier
c'est pas ça
il reste ce truc météo
y a un code
Bah voilà il y a des codes postal c'est ça c'est sur
Journal intime!
On va enfin apprendre ce qu'il a dit à Alice quand il l'a vu au Parc
Putain
Donc il est allé à des réunions du groupe de soutiens pour les ados LGBT
Il a avoué au club qu'il adorait le club de jeux de sociétés
Parce que c'est le sel endroit où il se sent femme
Mais en même temps ils se sont jamais doutés de rien parce qu'ils ne savent pas que c'est un homme
il y va avec sa perruque, il se fait appeler Samantha
Il travaille un peu sa voix, il se maquille, il met une jupe et un push-up et ils n'y voient que du feu
Au début il avait un peu du mal à s'y faire mais le fait qu'ils se soient rendus compte de rien ça la vraiment mise en confiance
c'est très bien
Donc Melissa ne sait pas que son copain est un transsexuel
Mais qu'il ne peux pas présenter Alice à Samantha (jolie erreur de texte, c'est Alice à Melissa mais passons)
Parce qu'aux yeux d'Alice il est Samantha, mais aux yeux de Melissa il est Samuel
Oh Putain j'avoue que c'est pas du tout simple comme situation
Oh putain la merde :
Le mec de Lola qui va au groupe de jeux de société
Il est aussi dans la même école que Sam
Du coup il as vu Sam en mode Samuel et Sam en mode Samantha
Il a tout dit à Lola, Lola a demandé des explications
Sam lui a tout expliqué
et c'est là que Lola l'as menacé et lui as dit de ne plus jamais mettre les pieds dans ce groupe de
jeux
Le 20 Décembre il est allé à la transPride
Donc un festival pour transsexuel
avec le groupe de soutien pour LGBT
et il s'y est senti super bien
ensuite il parle de l'anniversaire de son père
ou ses parents et Melissa ont débattus sur l'adoption par les couples homosexuel
C'est là qu'il a appris que Melissa sa copine était aussi peu ouverte sur le sujet que ses parents
Son père est carrément homophobe en fait
Le 31 décembre donc le soir où il a quitté Melissa
Il pensait que ça allait être une soirée qui allait de toute façon à cause de son vol retour
mais apparemment pas du tout elle avait même envie de sortir le grand jeu ce soir
elle qui m'avais toujours dit qu'elle voulais attendre le mariage
D'un coup elle m'envoyais une photo de lingerie qu'elle prévoyais de porter ce soir
Mais non pas moyen je ne me sentais juste pas capable
Oh non~~ c'est pour ça qu'il l'a quittée
Le 6 Janvier la mère de Melissa appelle Sam et lui dit que Melissa a fait une tentative de suicide le soir du nouvel an
Oh c'est horrible
C'est donc ça que Sam a dit à Alice quand ils sont allés au Parc ensemble
en suite son oncle, sa tante, son cousin sont venus passer le Week-End à la maison
Ils l'ont critiqués parce qu'il suivait pas l'actualité sportive
Lol
J'avais qu'une envie de tout le Week-End c'était de me barrer de partir à Covonia
Covonia c'est la ville où il est allé pour aller à la transPride
Le 28 Janvier
pfff, je n'en peux plus j'étouffe
J'aimerais voir le groupe LGBT mais ils sont fermés à cause d'un incendie
Ah oui il y a des fils de putes d'homophobes qui ont mis le feu au centre
Melissa ne veut plus entendre parler de moi,
Les parents sont chiants, les potes du lycée sont chiants
Je ne joue plus aux jeux de société j'en peux plus
Putain il y a plus un seul endroit où il peux se sentir bien et être lui même quoi
Et Phil lui a parlé d'un centre pour jeunes LGBT qui ne peuvent plus vivre chez leurs parents
Et le plus près est à Covonia
Messieurs
L'enquête est close
Aussitôt il a eu sa moto,
aussitôt il a foncé à Covonia
Pour enfin être qui il est
enfin s'assumer
et enfin être entouré de gens qui le comprennent
Clap Clap Clap
Bien joué Gamin
*Bip*
Wouh! Putain c'étais une tuerie ce jeu
n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous à plu
Moi j'ai liké 600 fois déjà
c'est une super belle histoire, c'est
très touchant et,
et c'est d'autant plus touchant que ça arrive dans la vraie vie
Les gens qui ne se sentent pas à leur place qui ne peuvent pas qui peuvent pas s'assumer à cause des autres
mais c'est pas forcément lié à l'orientation sexuelle
ça peut être carrément autre chose : un mec qui a une passion
et les autres ne comprennent pas cette passion et ils renient ça
franchement en vrai, qu'une personne soit Lesbienne, gay, bi ou transsexuelle
est ce qu'on n'en a pas rien à foutre?
Mais si!
Les gens font ce qu'ils veulent putain en quoi ça t'embête?
est ce que ça à une conséquence négative sur ta vie?
Non
FIN DU GAME
On finit sur une touche d'amour ou pas?
Que vous soyez hétéro, lesbienne, gay,  transsexuel, bi
bah je vous kiffe
Vous faites ce que voulez de votre cul et de vos parties génitales
ça ne me regarde pas
ha je le dis salement
et je vous dit à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir regardé
faites l'amour pas la guerre
ça n'a jamais été aussi bon de le rappeler
Peace!